هذا كما تعلم وكنت في
الاجتماع مع رئيس الولايات المتحدة
كان أول لقاء بين
الرئيس وولي العهد منذ
إدانة الرئيس لمحمد بن
سلمان ولي العهد على
درب الحملة عندما كان مرشحًا
ل  رئيس الولايات المتحدة ، لقد كنت
في الغرفة ، هل قام الرئيس بايدن برفع جمال
خاشقجي بالاسم
في البداية خلال حفل
الاستقبال ، ذكر الرئيس أن هذه قضية
ذكرها أنه أخذ تأكيدات السعودية بأبو
في ظاهرها صاحب
السمو الملكي ولي العهد أوضح
له  أن هذه كانت مأساة
للسعودية وأن
المسؤولين عنها قد تم
التحقيق معهم وواجهوا القانون وهم الآن
يدفعون ثمن الجريمة التي
ارتكبت ، ثم انتقلنا الحديث
فيما يتعلق
بالمناقشات الرسمية التي ناقشوها.
قضايا مهمة من حيث تنشيط
العلاقة من حيث
أمن الطاقة من حيث
الطاقة المتجددة ور  تغير المناخ
والمضي قدما في المستقبل
التهديد من إيران فيما يتعلق
بمكافحة الإرهاب وتمويل الإرهاب
من حيث العلاقات التجارية والاستثمارية
بين البلدين
اليمن أهمية الاستقرار والسلام في
الشرق الأوسط تكنولوجيا g5 g6 كيف
يمكن للبلدين  العمل من حيث
استكشاف الفضاء الخارجي والعديد من
الأشياء الأخرى ، فكان وزير انطباعك أن الرئيس بايدن
قبل تفسيرك لمقتل جمال
خاشقجي ، أعتقد ذلك ، لكنني أعتقد ذلك ،
نعم أعتقد
ذلك ولم يثره بعد الآن
طوال الوقت.  طبعا ما هناك
لتربية أه أه ذئب هذه
جريمة استنتج مجتمع المخابرات الأمريكي كما
تعلمون أن ولي العهد
أمرني فعليًا
بقتل جمال لا أعتقد أن
ذلك تم تحديده في هذين المصطلحين
رقم واحد اثنان أهه  كان التقييم
رقم ثلاثة ، فنحن نعرف ما
كان تقييم مجتمع المخابرات
فيما يتعلق بامتلاك صدام حسين
أسلحة الدمار الشامل  التدمير
أم
المملكة العربية السعودية حققت في
هذه الجريمة المملكة العربية السعودية حاسبت
المسؤولين عنها وهم يدفعون
ثمن الجريمة التي ارتكبوها ونحن
نتحدث نحن حققنا ونعاقبنا
واتخذنا إجراءات لضمان عدم حدوث
ذلك.  لا يحدث مرة أخرى ، هذا ما
تفعله الدول في مثل هذه المواقف ،
هذا ما فعلته الولايات المتحدة عندما
تم ارتكاب خطأ أبو غريب ،
وهذا ما تفعله الولايات المتحدة في المواقف الأخرى
التي تنطوي على عمليات قتالية أو تلك التي
تنطوي على موقف يتعدى فيه شخص ما
أو يتعدى عليه.  يرتكب خطأ
لأنك تعرف أن الرئيس بايدن كمرشح
يعتقد بالتأكيد أن تقييم المخابرات الأمريكية
قليل جدًا وقد أجريت محادثة مماثلة
فيما يتعلق بما
قاله الرئيس ترامب عندما كان في
مسار الحملة ، ما يحدث أحيانًا ما يقوله الناس
أثناء الحملة الانتخابية
لا ينعكس ذلك من حيث كونهم
في المنصب لأن لديهم إمكانية الوصول إلى
المزيد من المعلومات الاستخباراتية التي يمكنهم الوصول إليها  إلى
صورة أكمل وأوسع
عندما يفعلون هذه الأشياء وأعتقد
أن العلاقة بين
بلدينا هي علاقة استراتيجية مهمة للغاية لكلا
البلدين ونريد التأكد من
أننا نتقدم بها إلى مستوى أعلى
وأوسع وأعمق.
ربما سمعت أنه في مقابلة
قالت خطيبة خاشقجي السابقة إنها
تريد من الرئيس بايدن أن يسأل ولي
العهد أين جسد خاشقجي يمكن
لولي العهد أن يجيب على هذا السؤال
لم أر سؤالها ولا
أعرف أننا نعرف أين الجثة
لقد أجرينا تحقيقًا
ونشرنا نتائج هذا
التحقيق عندما أصدر
المدعي العام التهم ضد
المتهمين
كما تعلمون ، وثقت مجموعات حقوق الإنسان على
نطاق واسع ما
يزعمون أنه
سجن مستمر للمعارضين في المملكة العربية السعودية لقمع
النساء الأساسيات.  الإعدامات الجماعية الحقوقية
والمزيد سيقدم ولي العهد
التزامات محددة للرئيس
بينيت للولايات المتحدة بالفعل  يا العالم فيما يتعلق بمعالجة
هذه القضايا الأساسية لحقوق الإنسان ، فإننا
نتعامل مع التهم الموجهة
ضد المملكة العربية السعودية ،
أي شخص يُعاقب يخضع
لمراجعة قضائية ويتم توجيه الاتهامات من
قبل النيابة العامة ، والمحاكم تنظر
فيها ، والمدعى عليهم لهم
الحق  للاستئناف قبل أن يصبح القرار
نهائيًا تمامًا كما هو الحال في الولايات المتحدة ،
وللأسف ، فإن
العديد من التهم
التي يُعاقب الأشخاص بسببها لا
ينعكسها أولئك الذين يطرحون شكوكًا بشأن
المملكة العربية السعودية ونظامها القانوني
، فلنتحدث عن قضية رئيسية أخرى وهي:
لنفترض أنه جاء أه الإمدادات النفطية
هل طلب الرئيس بايدن من
السعودية زيادة إنتاج النفط على أمل
أن يخفض سعر
البنزين في الولايات المتحدة وليس
بالخصوصية لأن
الرئيس يعلم أن أه قضية الطاقة
هي قضية  العرض والطلب أه
مسألة موازنة الأسواق
السعودية ملتزمة بضمان
الاستقرار في أسواق النفط في الولايات المتحدة
تدرك الحكومة هذا الأمر ، فإن مسألة
الزيادات في أسعار البنزين التي
رأيناها مؤخرًا هي في الحقيقة
وظيفة من وظائف الجغرافيا السياسية وعلم النفس
أكثر من كونها تتعلق بطلب العرض الأساسي.
من قدرة التكرير في
الولايات المتحدة مقارنة بنقص المملكة
العربية السعودية استعدادًا لزيادة إنتاج النفط
، أوضحت المملكة العربية السعودية على
مدى العقود الماضية أنها تسعى إلى
ضمان استقرار السوق من خلال النظر في
أساسيات العرض والطلب
وأنها تعمل  داخل أوبك والآن داخل
أوبك بلس لضمان تزويد الأسواق
بالنفط الخام بشكل كافٍ
، زادت السعودية إنتاجها من النفط
خلال العام الماضي بشكل كبير
وفقًا لمتطلبات
السوق وهذا وضع
يتم تقييمه باستمرار من قبل
طاقتنا  وزارة وخبراء في هذا
المجال لتحديد ما إذا كان مطلوب المزيد من
النفط أو أقل من النفط المطلوب
لا الرئيس  لا تضغط علينا في
هذا الموضوع فالرئيس يدرك أن
السعودية أه حريصة على الحفاظ على الاستقرار
في أسواق الذئب الرئيس لم
يأت هنا للضغط على سعودي جاء الرئيس
هنا لعقد لقاء مع أحد
أهم أمريكا.  الحلفاء في
العالم وفي المنطقة
نواجه تحديات مشتركة نحتاجها
للعمل معًا
للتغلب على العديد من الفرص التي
نرغب في الاستفادة منها لأنه جاء
إلى هنا للتشاور حول مختلف
القضايا وكيف يمكننا المضي قدمًا.  من أجل
ضمان أن تكون السنوات الثمانين القادمة
إيجابية مثل السنوات الثمانين الماضية في
علاقتنا ، أوضح الرئيس
بايدن أنه يريد من المملكة العربية السعودية
أن تفعل ما قامت به الإمارات العربية المتحدة
والبحرين وبعض الدول العربية الأخرى.
العلاقات
مع إسرائيل هي المملكة العربية السعودية مستعدة
لتطبيع العلاقات مع إسرائيل وإذا
كنت كذلك عندما
قلنا أن
المملكة العربية السعودية تدعم مبادرة السلام العربية
في الواقع نحن
لقد أوضحنا أن
السلام يأتي في نهاية هذه
العملية وليس في بدايتها ،
كما قلنا أن الدول التي وقعت
على الاتفاقيات الإبراهيمية مع إسرائيل
هي قرارات سيادية اتخذتها تلك
الدول ونأمل أن  هذه
القرارات سيكون لها تأثير إيجابي على
المملكة العربية السعودية المحلية على استعداد
للانضمام إلى اتفاقيات إبراهيم ،
أوضحنا أننا بحاجة إلى عملية
وأن هذه العملية يجب أن تشمل
تنفيذ مبادرة السلام العربية
وبمجرد أن نكون
ملتزمين.  إلى تسوية على أساس دولتين مع
دولة فلسطينية على الأراضي
المحتلة وعاصمتها القدس الشرقية ،
هذا مطلبنا للسلام
حتى لا يتغير
ولا لم يتغير ، ونحن أه
اتخذنا مواقف أه وأوضحنا
أن السلام  هل السلام المحتمل هو
خيار الأنواع ، نعم إنه خيار استراتيجي
ولكن هناك
متطلبات معينة يجب أن تحدث قبل أن
يحدث هذا ، فماذا أنت؟
يقولون أن هذا لن يحدث حتى يكون هناك ما
يسمونه حل الدولتين إسرائيل
ودولة جديدة لفلسطين نعم هذا هو
موقفنا